Any Nation is defined by its propaganda
propaganda is that thing which unites us
my father was arrested by the KGB how
does Russian propaganda War you say one
thing you mean another thing when Putin
tells the whole world that there are no
Russian soldiers in crimeia we know that
this is a lies but this is what our
audience wants we've got to give it to
them how do we counteract troll Farms
the problem is not one person saying a
lie the problem is Thousands or hundreds
of thousands of fake accounts saying it
sometimes America will be a great
partner sometimes America will be the
worst partner there are some places
where Ukraine can start a new
communication the West usually ignores
the collective responsibility we're
trying to shorten the distance between
truth and Justice Russian propagandists
can we bring them to trial
Nas is the main most successful
propaganda line Ukraine has completely
Rewritten the rule book is now a model
for for other
democracies hi everyone everyone my name
is Julia timoshenko and you're watching
ukrainer in English and a series in
which we talk to different journalists
academics experts from different fields
and countries on their perspective on
Ukraine the Russian invasion and its
Global impact and today you have a
chance to look at the perspective of
Peter panv um a British academic a
senior fellow at John Hopkins University
and an author of two books about
disinformation and propaganda nothing is
true and everything is possible and this
is not propaganda Peter thank you thank
you so much for being with us today my
pleasure uh we're recording this
interview in kib today and you were born
in kib can you give a little bit more um
of your biographical background for
those who maybe not familiar with it
well it's all in my second book this is
not propaganda which which is a a mix of
memoir and uh propaganda
storytelling um but yeah I was born here
my parents are are from here um but but
my father was arrested by the KGB in
7778 um the year I was born and and like
many sort of dissident of that era he
was exiled from the former Soviet Union
um so really I only had time to throw up
over the USSR and my parents left when I
was 9 months old so I grew up they ended
up in England after Many Adventures and
I grew up in England um so I only really
knew about kib as this place and my
passport and I think the first time I
visited here I must have been 18 or
something something like that um so it
was sort of a mythical place for me
growing up uh my mother especially was
obsessed with finding somewhere in
Western Europe that looks like Kev so we
lived in Munich we lived in London she
was always going I want to live
somewhere that looks like Kev and so uh
and she found places like that in
different cities um uh yeah yeah so so
it was a bit of a revelation when I came
here and realized oh that's what my
mother was talking about and how did
your um identity I think like because as
you said you left from here when you
were N9 months old but then um it feels
like your um identity of being from here
really shaped your academic and uh
writer career as
well oh that's a great question how does
it shape my identity so I I write about
propaganda but but
I don't write about it like a political
scientists or even like a media and
Communications
experts um I'm interested in propaganda
and the way it relates to Identity um I
think the essence of powerful propaganda
often malign propaganda is
shaping uh models of identity that are
malign and harmful um and rescuing
people from their sense that they're
unsure about their identity that's what
it plays on so growing up um as an
imigra growing up constantly moving
between countries and
cultures I think I lived in sort of six
or
seven different cities by the time I
was a teenager made me very aware how um
identities are molded and changed by
different cultures and by Propaganda in
in The Wider sense of the word so so
that I think made me very tuned to this
idea that that people are very
much under the influence of of what some
academics call sociological propaganda
movies culture language
stereotypes um and that we adapt and
change to them and that made me ask a
lot of questions about Freedom when are
you really yourself when are you uh
under the influence of others um so I
think that sort of igra childhood made
me think a lot about these things
because it was so noticeable and I saw
it on myself every time I moved a
country I would change every time I
learned a language I would change every
time I moved cities I would change and
that made me thinkable who am I then I
suppose you know so I was fascinated by
those things anyway um and and then
there was just the the the the the
problematic case of Russian propaganda
and its influence on Ukraine which has
been going for centuries but really
became very active since 2004 so someone
who was really thinking about propaganda
and the way that then gets weaponized
and those needs and vulnerabilities get
weaponized um I started looking at at
the case of Russian influence in Ukraine
relatively early not that early but but
relatively early um but but I think just
just that really um I I don't know I've
never thought about it deeper than that
I like being here um my friends and
family are here um but I've I've never
really directly thought like Ukraine
propaganda my interest in propaganda is
is part of my sort of international life
I mean I I do a lot of work in America
now in Germany and in Sweden so I
haven't actually been purely fixated on
Ukraine and since we already started
talking about uh propaganda and it's
such a loaded term could you try to
Define that for those who Maybe have I
mean there's various definitions I'm
sure but some people think that it's
like purely this like horrible negative
thing other people say like no it's kind
of like everything is propaganda so like
what is not propaganda like how do you
explain that so yeah so so in my last
book this is not propaganda I
specifically don't use the word um apart
from the title simply because it's so
loaded and everyone has their own
interpretation and academics can't agree
what it means there's you know many many
definitions of it in the new book that
I've just finished I actually literally
finished it on Friday doing the
footnotes um there I explore the term a
lot um it's sort of unavoidable it's a
history book it's about the second world
war and that all the characters are
using it all the time so I mean the main
thing is just Define the way you're
using it at any time but you're quite
right some people will say it's just any
type of mass persuasion which is done in
the interests of those doing the
persuading yeah so there's some people
would say there's no morality to that if
it's if if the message or the cause is
moral then it's moral if the cause is
immoral then it's immoral but there's no
a prior Morality In It many others would
say that it always involves some sort of
manipulation of the other people where
the audience don't quite understand
what's going on so in that sense there's
an inequality in the
relationship um and therefore it's
somehow deceptive which is the way it's
usually used yeah so you know the
classic case that's used in America is
um around environments you know there
was a a very famous bill by the
Republican Party called the Clean Air
bill or something and it was actually a
way to allow for uh more pollution so
that's a classic case I mean you say one
thing you mean another thing so so
that's how it's hugely used
um the sort of deeper way of looking at
it which is the way that a philosopher
called Jack UL uses it by the way I
don't know if anything of this is
interesting so you'll probably cut this
out is very interesting but um
philosopher called Jack UL uses it who's
probably the most interesting
philosopher on this question he talks
about different layers of propaganda he
talks about political propaganda which
is campaigns PR that kind of superficial
thing that we often discuss whether
positive or negative but then he talks
about what he calls sociological
propaganda which are sort of the deeper
myths and stories that we need to
survive as a society so if we're talking
about America things like you know the
American dream the American way of life
these sort of big
ideas without which society a modern
technological Society can't really
survive yeah his argument is that when
we move from kind of little rural
societies to Big Urban societies where
where people don't really know each
other people become United by technology
by mass media and in order to survive as
a community propaganda is that thing
which unites us any nation is defined by
its
propaganda he'd still say that it can be
a very negative thing because his idea
is that these myths
become these myths become sort of
subconscious so we're not analyzing them
yeah so going back to something like the
American dream there's nothing wrong
with the American dream as long as it's
an idea that you can criticize and
engage with his sense was that with
sociological propaganda it becomes a
myth and sort of people just live in it
and because they're just living in it
and not analyzing it they become very
possessive of it they become very
aggressive to anyone they fear as
threatening it and they sort of cling on
to it and it leads to very very
undemocratic attitudes so anybody who's
not following the American way of life
suddenly becomes an enemy so that's a
much more sophisticated way of doing it
um again he would say that propaganda is
inevitable propaganda is the way that we
unite as Community communities in an age
of Technology you know that's a much
deeper way of looking at it I
think the whole issue set gets more and
more interesting as you move away from
the supply side of propaganda the
creation of bots and trolls and messages
to the demand side which is why do
people
want all of those things why do they
want the disinformation why do they want
the persuasion how do they react to it
and and why do they need the deeper
sense of community and worldview so it's
very interesting because it's almost
like makes people not just like the
objects to what like the propaganda
throws on but they almost like agents in
it because you say that they want uh
they actually need that for their social
life listen even on the level of the
most Bal political propaganda which is
what usually people focus on the sort of
like you know the campaigns that we all
see and analyze and react to um the
success of any
propagandist in the sense of a spin
doctor a PR person political campaigner
is basically to understand their
audience and to make their message fit
the audience that's that is success and
the better you are at that the more
successful you are and the worse you are
at that the less successful you are so
that is the when you look at it from the
point of view of the propagandist that
is the main question they're asking
themselves when they get up in the
morning their question is how do I
understand the audience better than my
rival and how do I reach them better
than my rival it is a
Non-Stop activity in audience analysis
and and the reason journalism in its
classic
sense pretty much always loses to any
type of campaign whether it's
advertising positive negative
disinformation information is because
journalism often doesn't think about its
audience in the Deep way that they do
and as long as we keep on doing that
we'll keep on losing now there's lots of
question of what is a journalist I mean
there's lots of media who are doing
propaganda so Fox News in America it's
only concerned with understanding its
audience and giving them the information
or the disinformation they want there
was just a case in America
where uh Fox News knew perfectly well
that they were giving lies saying that
the last election was stolen and there's
emails between going we know that this
is a lies but this is what our audience
wants we've got to give it to them but I
mean Fox News aren't really a media in
any serious philosophical sense of the
word um so they're thinking like
propagandists and they got in trouble
because officially their media so they
had to pay a billion dollars in fines
for this 780 million and fines all of
this is a race to understand people
better understand their needs their
desires their fears their
resentments and that's the whole
game I want to go back a little bit as
well to your specific focus on Russia in
Russian propaganda because it sounds
like it's almost like there is no such
difference between social and political
propaganda it's almost like Allin ones
because it's so uh intrinsic in that
Society
uh how does Russian propaganda work both
for the Russian audience inside but also
in the world as a whole uh what do you
mean by how does it work like what's
what's the main kind of maybe tools that
it employs maybe what are the main
insecurities if it's like domestic
audience or U the foreign audience that
it abuses in a way to uh send a message
that either the government or what we
call like a propaganda machine because
very often we say like a Russian
propaganda machine but is it actually a
machine are there different actors is
like the society also partaking in that
process so in in the Soviet tradition
and in the Russian tradition which is an
inheritor of it propaganda has taken
very seriously propaganda is Led from
the highest levels of political power
and while there are many actors involved
it is centrally coordinated and
centrally managed and it is taken very
very seriously um the propagandist has
always had a very privileged role in the
political system from Lenin onwards you
know they have this exalted role which
they don't really have in Western
governments in America there is no
propaganda tar there is no sort of
information s just doesn't exist um
there's um a small Department in in the
state department that thinks about
global engagement with a with a very
limited budget and very little power so
the Russians take it seriously firstly
and it goes right to the top it's it's
you know controlled from from the
presidential
Administration um there's a little bit
of a division of powers between internal
external between television and digital
um like everything in the Russian system
it sets up competing Powers who are
meant to compete with each other that's
the way the system works so it's quite
flexible but but it's centrally
coordinated and it is um taken taken
very seriously um so I mean I mean
that's that's maybe the first thing to
say about it the Chinese as well um
these sort of regimes take propaganda
very very seriously and and it's Central
to their idea of how to control their
own societies and how to manipulate
others so firstly secondly there's no
shame around the world propaganda
propaganda is seen as part of what you
do part of what the powerful should do
an essential part of governance and if
anything there is a scathing attitude
towards the idea of media there is know
I concept of what in democracies is
thought of as the public sphere a place
where people are meant to debate with
each other and and exchange opinions
where media are play a key role in this
sort of rough and tumble of democracy um
there's no belief in this um it's either
accused of being inefficient but usually
it's just accused of being corrupt so
the BBC is actually government or media
are all just tools of various secret um
cabals of of powerful
Elites um and so the idea of media
existing as an independent force is
dismissed this is just you know the mask
of democracy which is actually
controlled by vested interests and and
the argument if you want to call it an
argument is that at least dictatorships
are honest and um they don't play at
this ridiculous idea of a public sphere
or if they say the public sphere does
exist they say it's terribly inefficient
they say look at this chaos of democracy
it's complete chaos this is not the way
to run a country in the 21st century you
need centralized control you need
propaganda or else you have America
which is in chaos or Ukraine they often
say look at Ukraine it's chaos yeah
that's that's what the Russians and the
Chinese think I don't know if that's the
answer you're looking for but no this is
this is very interesting and um on the
role of Technology there because a lots
of people saying like oh we're living in
the age of so much
information uh but then in your book
you're actually discussing how it it's
actually more um dangerous in in a way
more um it's a better environment almost
for propaganda to exist like you
mentioned the troll Farm in the suburbs
of St Petersburg that was founded by pan
and he actually admitted to it recently
how does I guess like what's the
responsibility of technological
Giants um and actors in that and how do
we counteract troll farms in in their
existence so okay we're talking
specifically about troll farms uh we
usually associate troll Farms with what
the tech companies Now call coordinated
inauthentic Behavior so it's not about
the existence of one lie or two lies
it's the mass creation of deceptive
online accounts and officially the most
of the platforms have said they now have
a policy of of battling that and
stopping that activity the question is
enforcement so I think we're much I
think the debate has been won around
troll Farms the question is enforcements
what is the punishment for it so let's
say you're a troll Farm you've been
caught your accounts gets shut down who
cares you order you open up a th more
yeah the tech companies say they're
regulating this field but they police
themselves we have no access to how they
do this so I think the we've had the
debate about this for the last seven
years and it was a long journey because
at first there was this very reactive
and naive uh response let's capture
every bit of disinformation firstly
disinformation is not a legal term so
what does that mean capture
disinformation and B it's pointless on
the internet trying to grab every little
lie so so there was a journey of
understanding for the expert Community
the policy Community um I was involved
in the Parliamentary committee on
disinformation fake news in Britain from
thinking about individual lies and
pretty much getting rid of the term
disinformation because there was no way
you can really use it
legally two because it just doesn't
exist as a legal term
two thinking about coordinated deceptive
Behavior the problem is not one person
saying a lie the problem is Thousands or
hundreds of thousands of fake accounts
saying it so you go after the system not
after every piece of information or
disinformation that that was a correct
process because it understood the
essence of what was new about the
internet um there are existing laws
about speech yeah changing those laws is
going to be very very hard what is new
about the internet is not speech what is
new about the internet is the way you
distribute the speech so if you want to
bring in new laws you go after that so
so so there's been a journey to do that
and and there's been laws pasted about
that and and the question is enforcement
and who's responsible and and Punishment
I mean so let's say you're a PR Company
let's forget about pran you're a PR
Company in Britain and you do these fake
campaigns I mean all that will happen is
that the accounts get shut down so until
there's some real punishment for it
people will keep on doing it what kind
of punishment do you think there should
be for I'm not a lawyer and not a judge
some something that stops them doing it
again fine a fine at least would be nice
some sort of you know something
something yeah um and on contrary to
troll Farms um there are lots of real
people who I mean they're not part of
this uh organized activity who believe
very like straight up insane information
when it comes to Ukraine obviously there
a lot of things about the climate uh
when it comes to Ukraine it's like
Ukraine bombing done bus for eight years
and bio us biolabs and all of those like
almost nonsense and um it's really hard
to engage with them but should we even
is there a point of engaging with these
kind of people that are so um I guess
like live in their own informational
World um is there a way to persuade them
in your
opinion okay uh so so Julie you you led
a lot of really interesting language
here so
these people so are we sure that these
people are one homogeneous Mass I want
to slightly one slightly risks doing the
propagandist work for them when you say
they are one people one people M so the
first thing you do is try to analyze
them so for example in Co we did a lot
of work in DNR lot of focus groups
inside DNR and also in Russian speaking
groups in Estonia just trying to look at
the co question
and why weren't how did people feel
about vaccines and and so on and so
forth and it was very interesting I mean
we also a lot of research that we did
well my university did in Baltimore and
people who are vaccine Skeptics part of
them believe in Crazy conspiracy
theories so they're often it's a case of
okay you know CLA you know this this
could be people with just deep deep deep
emotional issues a lot weren't a lot had
had terrible experiences with the
medical profession in the US in Ukraine
uh the occupied territories and in
Estonia they didn't trust sort of like
the medical profession because they' had
horrible experience with this medical
profession in Soviet times a lot of them
had memories of Chernobyl they'd been
completely traumatized by Chernobyl and
the idea that you put anything in your
body is it's fake so what I'm saying is
you know never call them these people
the moment you've done that you've lost
that means you've already given the
audience to the other side your job is
to start analyzing the audience and
understanding okay this is the Hardcore
who you know you probably don't even
want to re start to engage the second
thing you said is
persuade persuade to what end what is
our aim here it's our aim to what to get
them to use other sources of media is
our aim to stop them from voting for
fascist parties is our aim to make them
not fight so again what's the aim what I
would definitely get rid of is
a a desire to search for some sort of
morality tale are they good or bad
that's largely irrelevant especially in
the context of War um that's something
for education to think about what is a
good citizen and stuff like that if
we're talking about a war whether a hot
War like here or kind of a cold war
because you know well even though it
doesn't want to admit it the collective
West is now on a cold war Russia while
there Sim while having a hot War at the
same time um you really have to move
away from
from caring whether these people are
good or bad um that's a real fake search
that's completely irrelevant what we
have to do is win and so winning will be
who understands these audiences better
and winning is understanding what you
want them to do so those are the
questions we need to be asking how do
you assess Ukraine's um work in the
information AAL front if you if you
analyzed it in the past I think I think
Ukraine has completely Rewritten the
rule book um and I think is now a model
for for other democracies they've
proved and whatever one feels about the
current government what they've
completely proved is that a democracy
can
do
International let's call them public
information campaigns cuz you don't want
to use the word propaganda
International public information
campaigns that are effective so
basically what's happened in the last 30
years in the west is that we've
completely lost our self-belief around
doing something called public
diplomacy you know the idea that Western
leaders can talk to the populations
across the world we used to do this in
the Cold War quite well did it in the
second world war really well just think
of church
speeches the last 30 years we've
completely lost the gift of it and we
had a terrible experience
what terrible experience we created a a
disaster a
tragedy and and a horror around the war
on terror which was the last time we
tried to do it so there is now an
allergy of doing this sort of public
information and zilinsky and his team
have shown that a leader of a democracy
can talk to Nations across the world
reach them and engage them to such level
that zalinski is now probably the second
most popular politician if not the most
popular po politician in most countries
in in in in in democracies they've
completely Rewritten the
ruberg and you know I live in Washington
and and whenever I asked the sort of
people in power in Washington like why
don't we do more you know public
information campaigns to counter the
Russians and they're like oh we can't do
that dictatorships do that we don't do
that and like well historically we have
actually and the fact is that we've lost
the gift and and we
have
got um you know and and what we've done
we've done terribly the last 30 years so
I think he's completely and it's a
zalinsky thing frankly he's completely
Rewritten the rule book and it's a sort
of it's a
new it's a new positive example of how
you can do Democratic communication 21
so it's been amazing so that's been very
very strong um it'll get it gets harder
with every year because as the war
continues it's hard to keep that going
then it's important not just to rely on
zalinski um because people need more
characters than that um and also there
are many more stories that need to be
told and I guess you guys are doing that
um and then there's the question of
audiences Beyond democracies where
Ukraine finds it harder to make inroads
because countries don't care countries
historically were allied with the Soviet
Union countries in Africa and Latin
America or countries want to be like
Russia they like what Russia is doing
they want to go and invade their
neighbors as well and they see Putin as
a great example yeah that was actually
my um next uh question specifically
about Ukraine's I guess Communications
impact in the global South and other
countries that are not really
democracies um do do you see any hope of
any kind of
message um reaching them in a positive
way for Ukraine so there's a lot of talk
in European capitals and in kib as well
and in DC now of something called and I
think I'm responsible for this an
information
Ramstein which which is an idea I
floated after doing a bunch of research
at the start of the war but really
thinking about how can the Allies work
together for exactly this sort of
question what do you do with the harder
Communications challenges
and I think it really is about allies
coming together and thinking how we can
help each other so there are places
where Ukraine speaks directly really
well there are some places where Ukraine
can start a new communication Taiwan
Japan you know countries that see a
parallel between China and Russia and
are seeing a parallel in their
experience and there are other countries
which just do not
give ad them yeah and you can start you
can start telling them about how Ukraine
has amazing you know digital technology
and that's really important but that's
longterm yeah so that's when you start
talking to your allies that's going okay
we can't really make an inroad here how
can you help us there could be Ukraine's
allies who have leverage in those
countries there could be Ukraine's
allies like Ireland who have great
relationships with Latin American
countries so how can allies all start
using their information leverage which
is often connected to financial leverage
as well let's be let's be honest it's
never just just information it's often
about trade often about investment how
do we start using that in a coordinated
way to be more than the sum of our parts
um sometimes America will be a great
partner sometimes America will be the
worst partner so working that out and
then prioritizing I mean you just called
it the global South again it's not your
fault that term is used term but it's
it's a terrible term I mean we're
talking about what three quarters of the
world we're saying is one thing Latin
America is completely different Dynamics
every country around Venezuela loades
Russia because they've supported
Venezuela and have created this flood of
violence crime and refugees spreading to
their countries they detest Russia so
there are very very anti-russian
countries in Latin America and there are
countries like Brazil who are Russia's
deao allies so again never call it one
thing again break it down think about
where the ins are but also think about
what matters cuz cuz maybe a lot of this
is wasted
energy and this talk is incredibly
interesting and I wish we had more time
to talk specifically about propaganda
and
disinformation and how we can be better
in using the tools that you're
describing for for Ukraine's benefit
specifically but I also want to talk
about the Reckoning project and what
you're doing right now could you
describe a little bit more about that no
but the Reckoning project is all about
that so so I
mean generally since 2015 both my
academic work and in my sort of media
work I sort of decided very early that I
didn't want to do backf foot stuff I
don't want to analyze what the other St
side is doing I want to think much more
about what we do and virtually all the
research that I do at University is
about how do you create pro-democratic
media that can compete
with authoritarian propaganda so I'm I'm
actually not that obsessed of looking at
the other side too much uh simply
because other people do that really well
but also because because my background
is is much more in the creative side of
things I sort of I went to film school I
made documentaries I write books I I I
like to create things I don't analysis
as part of that but only as an a preface
to Creation so the Reckoning is is one
of the Strategic responses uh to
disinformation and more importantly
impunity um you know when Putin tells
the whole world that I don't know there
are no Russian soldiers in Crimea back
to 2014 or now makes ridiculous claims
around buter it's not disinformation
he's not trying to trick anyone he's
trying to say I don't care I'm going to
lie I'm going to murder and there's
nothing you can do about it they're not
hiding their war crimes very hard yeah
so how do we end the impunity yeah we
live in this weird world where we have
so much information so much access to
evidence and very
little enforcement or punishment or
Justice that comes at the end of it so
the idea of the Reckoning is how do we
bridge the gap from truth to justice so
very simply we put two groups of people
together who usually hate each other and
get them to cooperate journalists and
lawyers why do they usually hate each
other because lawyers work for their
clients who are
often I mean that's all they do they
have client and they serve that client
and their clients are often the people
that journalists are trying to are
trying to bring shed some light
over um because
lawyers because I mean it's a profession
that's that's that's dedicated to to
serving your clients but I think in this
case in the case of war crimes it's not
so I think when it comes to war crimes
we're actually allies here we're allies
in the search for truth and and justice
so I think in this case we can put our
usual differences aside and work
together towards this greater cause um
as and as many other people are as well
we have journalists we have around 12 20
various different times Ukrainian
journalists Ukrainian team doing this
really really really deep analysis of
different war crimes in Ukraine so we
don't just go there and leave like most
journalists do we will stay on one crime
scene 6 months a year as long as we need
to be and we're not just doing
journalistic interviews we're Gathering
evidence which is in line with
international human rights law so the
journalists have been trained by lawyers
and others to make sure when they do
interviews they don't ret traumatize
people they do no harm they gather
evidence in such a way that it can be
used for trial later which is much more
rigorous than when journalists do it so
they gather their EV they didn't create
Amazing Stories out of this we were the
front cover of time we do a lot of work
the Atlantic Vanity Fair also in the
Philippines and in in getting some stuff
ready for South
Africa so doing that but then we've got
this incredible archive which our legal
team is going through looking for
patterns and then thinking which
prosecutions around the world the ha
Europe Ukrainian prosecutor do we work
with in order to start to build cases so
what are we trying to I mean it is very
much for me anyway um a way to push back
against the putins of this world they're
trying to say that facts don't matter
the truth doesn't matter and there is no
justice we're trying to shorten the
distance between truth and Justice so I
see it completely as a strategic
response to to disinformation and and
impunity um and it's the sort of
creative responses we need um I mean
it's fantastic to do debunking
factchecking they're really important
but they're very passive what we have to
do is start you attacking the you know
the basis uh on which authoritarian
propaganda builds its power
um and part of that directly then is
looking into the question of the legal
culpability of Russian propagandists can
we bring them to trial can we increase
sanctions on them now that's one of the
things that we're beginning to look at
it's very challenging because usually
propagandists get away with it
historically at nurenberg for example
the
main uh the head of the reichs radio so
so Hitler's kilov or Hitler simonan uh
got away with it he found not guilty you
couldn't prove the his connection his
name was H spriter you couldn't prove
his connection to the crimes he was just
a talking head that was his argument I
just say stuff I don't know I don't know
what happened afterwards I'm not in the
military I'm not in the concentration
camp guard I just say stuff and words
who knows and classically propagandists
are protected by freedom of speech
America has been very reluctant to
sanction the propagandists the Russian
propagandists sort of ch Ching slowly
but very slowly and classically you know
not only is disinformation not not not a
crime in any kind of serious country um
but
even um things like hate speech you
know the lore around them is very very
vague some of the language that Russia
is using and Russian propaganda is using
does sound a lot like incitement to
genocide and I know there's people
working on that side which is amazing
and and certainly if a genocide case can
be brought against Russia an incitement
to genocide as part of that that'll be
incredibly important but that can risk
missing a lot of the
everyday everyday the everyday
atrocities that Russia does so what I'm
very focused on is thinking about the
connection of propaganda to specific war
crimes to crimes against humanity so if
we get genocide amazing but that's a
really really high bar I want to sort of
change the
everyday integration of propaganda
into things like the attack on the
maternity hospital in maral or the
bombing of katos what was the aim of the
propagandists in those operations which
are clearly war crimes and if we can
show that they are integrated they had a
sense of what was going on then I think
we might be able to breaking your ground
and do you see so far ways in which
those two are connected well we can see
them firstly so what we will start with
we're just starting this legal research
moves slowly uh but but um we're trying
to make it faster but it slow so what
you would look at is things like and
this is where your troll Farm thing is
very interesting and this is why the
digital thing is very interesting what
you would look at you know were there a
thousand telegram accounts and 20
YouTube channels in
the prease to the attack saying the same
things more and more frequently which is
quite easily traceable through digital
technology so you couldn't really do
that in the second world war you you can
really it's much harder to do that in
that time so if you could show that and
show okay look in the days before the
attack you know mentions of as of
battalions in marup hospital go up XXX
perent you're like okay this is
interesting this is already showing some
sort of coordinated Behavior so who's
responsible for that behavior what are
the connections between the troll farms
and the presidential Administration are
there any emails that have come to light
which show that so you'd have to show
what's Happening the in the propaganda
how it relates to what's happening on
the ground and then you'd have
to
establish how the system works so those
are the questions you would look at and
um I do think that we already
saw Russia using
propaganda in a very integrated way with
its various war crimes in
Syria so there's people already looked
at this in Syria and have already seen
those patterns and you
know there is plenty of research to get
into regarding they're doing it today so
those are the things I want to look at
yeah we're just starting yeah I assume
it's a very long um process
unfortunately obviously we all would
like to see it faster but how do you see
the the general I guess Road of justice
for Ukraine and bringing these people to
Justice what are maybe the things or a
key step that needs to happen because
for a lot of ukrainians give an argument
well they we need to first win and sort
of win on the battlefield and then it
will bring the Justice after that and
some people argue well it's not that you
know um that's
simultaneous so classically that's
what's happened you have the war then
you have 30 years while we look for the
war criminals then you have Justice I
mean no I think there's a demand to get
it quicker that's my sense I haven't
done any polling on it in Ukraine but I
think people want it sooner and I think
what's revolutionary about Ukraine is
that this stuff is happening as the war
is going on which I think is I think
that's a good thing but look I'm not a
lawyer um and when I think about Justice
and I think maybe we all should do that
we should think about Justice in all its
forms so obviously a tribunal the hag
Universal jurisdiction all these legal
IDE of Justice are great and we'll let
the lawyers do that but you know I'm
sure you've interviewed lawyers and
talked to lawyers we're talking about
three five 10 years sort of Cycles I
like to think about Justice or forms
there's Justice in the court of public
opinion there's Justice in the court of
sanctions I think there's a lot you can
do there there's economic Justice you
know who should be paying for the
Reconstruction of Ukraine all of these
are forms of justice and I think we have
to be thinking about all of those for
for justice and I think we have to be
talking about that all the the time and
and making sure that people understand
that these are all forms of Justice I
think we also have to understand that
it'll always be
unsatisfying um now we sort of look back
at nurenberg the trial of the Nazi
leadership as somehow satisfying it
wasn't at the time at all 12 Nazis were
found were executed afterwards there was
complete sense of dissatisfaction and
the trials that came afterwards I think
out of I can't remember out of hundreds
of thousands of Nazis put on trial
domestically in Germany only thousands
were found guilty
there was a complete sense of
Injustice and you know that was somehow
compensated by Israelis through sort of
mosad assassination gangs going around
capturing and killing Nazis but it's
never really there is no satisfaction I
think we can do a lot more than has been
done in the past if we do all those
things and then tell those stories but
we also have to be realistic there's
there's no real Justice for for the sort
of things that Russia is doing
always I
mean it'll never quite be satisfying you
know when it comes to the question of uh
public or Collective responsibility when
it comes
to um the German case but also Russia
today um I think a lot of ukrainians are
um dissatisfied with how the West
usually ignores the collective
responsibility uh and just calls it like
Putin's war and you know his gang and
stuff but uh for us we
see a lot of Russians are essentially
being complicit with it whether they're
being like completely you know silent or
um just overall not doing any action to
make it stop what's your personal views
on that and like I know that there is a
lot of like this sense of responsibility
versus guilt and whether making somebody
feel guilty is even like productive
thing um is it something that is so this
this question of collective I mean
firstly this is clearly not this
is Russia has been I mean talking about
the historical context the cultural
context Russia has been attacking
Ukraine for hundreds of years this is
just the latest
iteration um this has embedded Russia's
sense of ownership of Ukraine is
embedded in Russian literature Russian
education so the idea this is Putin just
came up with this is absurd I mean just
historically this is clearly part of
Russian culture and Russian history and
this is just what they do this is not
the first time they're trying a genocide
here so so I mean obviously it's not
just Putin I mean that's just you mean
that's really just ignoring history so
um and that's embedded in Russian
culture and Russian education and so
anybody if you're talking about what it
is this is this is part of the story
talking about people now I mean this
question of collective
responsibility God I mean there's the
legal bit of it which I don't really
understand and I think lawyers will will
struggle with that I'd love to see
sectoral sanctions for example I'd love
to see anybody who works on Russian
propaganda anybody connected to the war
machine should I think face sanctions
the West bulks at that I can never tell
whether they they don't want to do that
because of the what is collective
responsibility or whether it's just
technically a bit of a headache like
where do you get the lists how do you
know who work there so I can never tell
which excuse they're using but I mean I
think without a doubt that should be
happening and no I don't think there
should be normal travel visas during a
time of War they just wouldn't be in a
time of War imagine Britain was at war
with another country of course you would
change the Visa policy so the whole Visa
policy debate I find absurd you you
create new Visa policies befitting
what's going on and yeah you do better
Refugee visas I mean whatever you you
work on this of course you change the
Visa policy when a war started this sort
of War so so I I find that if you're
talking about the Visa issue I find the
excuses there absurd from the west but
the deeper question of responsibility I
don't know let's go back to the German
example so what are we 70 years after
the war and we're still debating were
Germans responsible for the Holocaust I
mean every year there's a book from
either side yeah um in 1946 kyl Jaspers
and Hannah Aon stuff fighting about this
so this is a very deep philosophical
question where I where you're quite
right it usually is the border between
responsibility and guilt yes they're
responsible does that make them guilty
and it becomes philosophical discussion
and for me it becomes completely
empty what I can say is this I'm going
to flip it on its
head and connected to propaganda because
this is something I do
understand those Russians that I speak
to who do feel a sense of responsibility
and they do exist not as a social
movement they don't exist but I
certainly speak to Russians who talk
about that completely and their sense of
responsibility and some of them
individually do do
something they're the
ones who are most resistant to Putin's
propaganda so Putin's propaganda is to
say you have no responsibility
Democratic agency doesn't exist yeah
n is the main most successful propaganda
line yeah his whole propaganda system is
built around the idea that the
individual doesn't matter and that you
can't change anything yeah you live in a
world of such vast conspiracies of so
much confusion you need an authoritarian
leader to lead you and people are
delighted to get rid of responsibility
and freedom and agency because it's
really hard to have them so for me it's
become like a a sort of a line okay if
you don't take
responsibility that means however much
of an oppositionist you are you're
actually still living within Putin's
propaganda model and sadly I hear this
from a lot of from a lot of people
who've left Russia who are very against
Putin they're like I don't take
responsibility so my response is that
means you're still living in his
propaganda
and I don't personally feel I actually
am in a position to judge I'm just
looking at it from the way
way language works and what it tells me
about the success of the
propaganda um I think UK ukrainians can
judge as in ukrainians who are citizens
of Ukraine and who are who are fighting
can judge I think Russians can judge
each other at the end of the day I'm a
I'm a I'm just a Londoner um so I don't
want to be doing the one doing the
judging I think ukrainians definitely
have the right to judge but when we talk
about the success of the
propaganda it's and we talk about myths
and we talk about sociological
propaganda this is what a lul talking
about yeah L saying doesn't matter the
disinformation campaigns you know that
is non I mean that's easy to
analyze but if you've bought into this
idea that it's not my responsibility
you're actually living inside Putin's
propaganda myth that you have no agency
you're still there you think you've left
you haven't you're still there and you
know and I see this in the sociological
research as in like the there's still a
lot of sort of focus groups and
interviews being done in Russia it's
very interesting reading
them because people will be say I don't
like the war and stuff like
that war skeptical or even say that
Putin you know it's a mistake
or they still repeat the
myths all these deeper psychological
myths repeat over and over and
especially the main myth of Putin
propaganda
you know he's saving us from chaos if
not Putin then chaos I mean insane I
mean like this from no but this is from
young people who fled the country who
are scared of being mobilized who like
completely are not invested in the war
from a really self-interested point of
view forget about the ideology like
personally they don't want to go and
fight and they'll still say this and
they don't remember the '90s and so the
idea to which despite on the conscious
level being opposed
for very self-interested reason being a
post war not because they like Ukraine
or anything but just because they don't
you know they don't want to die they
will still repeat the propaganda M so
that's what UL was talking about he's
talking the extent to which real
propaganda the really powerful one goes
really deep and sits inside these
mythical structures and you know I'm and
what I'm fascinated by is why those
ideas work why is something like
atas which for your English things
That's a classic of Russian propaganda
they we don't know who they are are
trying to bite a piece from
us or without Putin
chaos why is that so resonant why does
that work so powerfully why do people
inhabit this even when they consciously
might disagree with the w and also
why responsibility and this question of
responsibility is so important so anyway
those are things that we're going to
have to tackle if you really want to
start
undermining
the the Russian psychological system I
suppose that's incredibly interesting
especially I found like what you said
about um Russians who escaped or who are
living abroad and who oppos the war or
call them themselves like oppositionists
but say like I don't take
responsibility um and you're you're
claiming that actually no like if you
say that you live in the Putin's it's
only the ones who say I do take
responsibility who who might but but
they don't exist as a social group
they're individuals they haven't been
able to the ones who say I take
responsibility haven't been able to come
together in a
movement which okay inside Russia you
could say danger but the fact that they
haven't done that outside of Russia is
shows just how deep the propaganda goes
the fact that even outside of Russia
they think they have no agency they
can't change anything that whole set of
attitudes is
exactly one of the main messages of
Putin
cander and and that has been I think
even to me who saw I mean I read a Blood
book about it uh but but to see that
play out
now and the lack
of the lack of a strong anti-putin
movement outside of Russia for the
millions who've left has just been I
mean it's horrible when you see your own
work
conf just I just
like
weird could I say like the Germans who
left Nazi Germany did more than the
Russians who've left pu Russian and
what's your thoughts on U the the
leaders of the opposition the team and
there there is no opposition political
movement again it's you know um the B's
in in jail because it also seems like a
like a tool for propaganda to like show
that there is you know to give an Oscar
to show how like a hero he is for the
world he's in jail it's in Jey um it's
just a question of you know
Effectiveness they had Great Hopes they
could change Russia and there's a you
know I don't know that's sort of a
separate story we'd have to analyze to
what extent they ever had a real
strategy to what extent they were you
seen I don't know it's sort of a there's
a long story of the the Journey of
Russian opposition as is you know
something we'd have to go right go back
to sort of to the 1990s to start
analyzing a book yeah well uh we're
going to be wrapping up soon but before
that I wanted to ask you since you visit
Ukraine very often right now what's your
favorite places in Ukraine that you
would recommend other people your
colleagues maybe to
visit future Ukraine's at War but um um
so either during or actually I mean a
lot of people think that Ukraine is like
entire Frontline and there's a debate
whether should should you come or not
and why you should come or not I mean
you come for whatever you want yeah but
but just you
know and and you can you can go to all
sorts of places and you can go to my
family's literary Festival in ch if you
if you're into into poetry festivals um
but um
um just you know whatever you do
wherever you come from just just bring a
couple of drones be useful it's great
that's great answer um yeah thank you so
much for doing this uh great interview
for me it personally was very very um
useful and I think eye opening a lot of
things in this topic um thank you so
much for everybody who's been watching
this if you enjoyed this video and our
series please subscribe to the channel
of ukrainer in English and continue
supporting Ukraine and yeah thank you so
[Music]
much